so our next speaker
uh that you know that causal inference
is so hot right now
uh we've had at this conference alone
we've had two con causal inference we've
had two casual inference uh talks and we
had a casual inference workshop on
wednesday and the meetup a few months
ago had a causal inference talk also
it's a really big topic these days
people are really excited about it and
you notice we've been doing a lot of fun
facts for everybody these like fun goofy
things our next speaker says that all
facts about her are serious
so please welcome jennifer
uh so the the
original title of my talk was deep down
everyone wants to be causal
and the reason is that basically we act
all the time on our presumed causal
knowledge of the world
so think about all the decisions you
made today just to get here
what subway were you going to take what
did you eat for breakfast how many
slices of pizza did you have for lunch
implicitly all of those decisions you're
making were based on your presumed
causal knowledge
sometimes you have data to back that up
lots of times you don't
right but we all make sense of the world
by thinking causally
now
luckily sometimes we do have data to
help us make the really important
decisions about policy or practice so i
want to introduce a tool to you today
that i hope will make
using that data to make causal inference
just a bit easier
the tool is called think causal
and we hope that it will make causal
inference easy understandable and fun
that's the goal
so i'm jennifer hill i'm from nyu and
excited to talk to you today
so the work we've been doing over the
past year or so to build this tool
has been a team effort
and i really especially want to give a
shout out to george perette who is here
somewhere there he is
who basically took my crazy ideas
and turned them into something tangible
which has been super exciting and i also
want to give credit to special credit to
joe marlowe and junky young who both
contributed an enormous amount to the
project
okay
so once again all the questions that we
think about the things we're trying to
solve
for policy and practice they're all
causal questions we can't make decisions
and expect we know what the impact will
be of those decisions
if we don't understand the causal
mechanisms involved
and if we get them wrong what's the cost
sometimes it's money
sometimes it's time
sometimes it's potential
it could be lives right if it's a
medical decision
so
the cost of getting the wrong answer can
be quite high and so we really should be
very careful about how we make progress
unfortunately at the same time causal
inference is hard
for any of you have learned a little bit
about it often i feel like after my
causal inference course people need a
little support group because they go in
thinking oh great i'll learn all the
fancy tools and they learn oh actually
this is just hard there are a lot of
assumptions you have to make
okay well what's the basic idea here the
basic idea is that we want to make fair
comparisons
right so if we've got a group of
kids who got a exposure to a program and
a group of kids who didn't
we're hoping that they're basically
exactly the same kids that's what
randomized experiments are trying to do
create replicas of the kids across both
groups so that if one group gets
high test scores and the other group
doesn't and the only thing that's
different between them is the treatment
hopefully we can safely attribute that
effect to the treatment and not to
something else
but most of the time we have data that
look more like this
the groups aren't the same so if we see
higher test scores in one group than the
other we don't know if that's because of
the program or because they came into it
with very different backgrounds and
characteristics and experiences
okay
so to make progress we often make this
strong assumption which is called
lots of different things but today i'll
call it all confounders measured
which says have we measured all the
characteristics that predict both
treatment receipt and the outcome
if we can confidently say that we can
make some progress
so
popular in the last i would say two or
three decades have been matching and
waiting
matching tries to create a matched
comparison group for a treatment group
that looks very similar based on what we
can observe
weighting has a very similar kind of
intuition but the weights can be
non-integers
but over the past years
modeling although
maybe a little less intuitive harder to
explain to your grandma
actually has a lot of fantastic
properties
because it allows us to get much more
accurate
answers to our questions
so here's the basic idea suppose there's
one confounder it's a pre-test
and we've got a post-test as our outcome
if we can model correctly model the
relationship between that pre-test and
post-test
then
for each person who's in the treatment
group which in this case are the red
dots
we just need to make a prediction of
what they would have looked like in the
control group
right that's their counter factual
outcome
so
if we can do a really good job modeling
we actually can make real progress so
all the tools that got thrown out for a
couple of decades we're now bringing
back
so we've got
a comparison between two predictions is
just an individual level treatment
effect if we get a bunch of them we can
average that up to an average treatment
effect
okay
that's cool but what if you've got the
wrong model so this dotted line that's
been sitting there the whole time is the
linear regression fit
it's not a good fit
right linear regression is great for a
lot of things but it makes actually some
pretty strong assumptions
so
with the advances of machine learning
why don't we
take advantage of that
so here i'm showing basically the same
response surface but with
the step function here the blue line
just represents
one regression tree fit to this response
surface which
is doing an okay job
but i want to sell to you
the idea of a more complicated model
called bayesian additive regression
trees which is the sum of regression
trees and the bart fit to this model is
represented by the dashed lines here and
this extends out if we have many more
predictors and more complications in our
data
okay so
from that we can get point estimates for
individuals or groups and since it's
embedded in a bayesian framework we can
get intervals which is really nice
okay so
show us the money what's happened how do
we know this actually works
of course in causal inference we never
know there's no equivalent of the kaggle
competition because there's no ground
truth but what we have in the causal
inference world are these competitions
that have been run since 2016
in conjunction with the atlantic causal
inference conference
um where there are you know hundreds or
thousands of simulated data sets and
teams try to you know compete to try to
get the right answer
so bart bayesian out of regression trees
was either the top or one of the top
performers in all of those competitions
that have been held so far
and it regularly outperforms propensity
score matching and waiting and a lot of
the standard things that are popular
right now
also yeah a bunch of scholarly articles
that stuff too
this is embedded in a
r package that's been around for a
couple years called bark cause
uh created by my collaborator vince dory
who's an amazing programmer so this
already exists on crayon it allows the
user to implement bart for causal
inference
shouldn't that be enough
why doesn't everyone use bark cause
well not everyone uses r that may seem
weird to the people in this room
but not everyone uses r
and some people
this is crazy don't like to use tools
they don't understand
so we thought what can we do
to remedy that problem
and that's what inspired think causal
think causal is a scaffolded
user-friendly way to access
sophisticated causal inference tools
and a crucial piece is that it has
educational components that allow for
just-in-time learning
so just as you're getting confused about
what you're doing
the goal is
that you can pop out and learn about it
just at that moment
how does it work
to do this we're going to do a silly
thing where i'm going to pretend
in a video to be a researcher who looks
like this if anyone can figure out how
to stop this thing i would love to know
okay
i'm pretending to be a data analyst at
the department of ed in big city
oops
i have a ba in economics i have a
master's in public policy
my preferred software package is stata
i have no formal training on causal
inference
i have lots of data tons of data on all
the kids in big city
uh and i'm asked to make policy
decisions or to help inform policy
decisions all the time
so here i am with lots of data
don't know much about causal inference
but i'm doing something that assumes
that i know the causal answers to
questions
that's a little worrisome
so the research question that today is
plaguing me is does early intervention
lead to higher test scores for at-risk
children
so indulge me in watching this video
okay so i am ready to try this new tool
thing causal anything that could make my
work life easier i am really willing to
try so first i guess i have to decide if
i want to learn or analyze
if i click on learn oh i see there are
all these different modules to choose
from
uh i like the fact that there are
monsters here that always makes me want
to learn more but
i'm not even sure i have time today to
learn something new so i suppose i'll
just jump right into analyzing
i've got a little welcome message
and the first thing i'm asked to do is
to select my causal s demand which
it looks like is some kind of average
treatment effect and right right away
i'm not
entirely sure what i need to do
so i'm going to click on unsure
which brings me to this learning module
on causal estimates
and it appears that this is embedded
within an example about the effect of
something called the hypershoe on
running times for marathon runners
so
it's great that i get to learn about
this in the context of an example that
i can at least vaguely understand even
if i'm not a runner
first we start with the factual data
which it turns out are the data we
actually get to see and what i'm
understanding from this
is that
while we can see differences in the
running times between the people who
wear the shoe and those who don't
that difference isn't necessarily
something causal
instead we have to think about
counterfactuals in other words we have
to think for each person what their
running time would have been
if they'd been in the alternate universe
where either they were
wearing the shoe or not wearing the shoe
okay and those define individual causal
effects and i can look at the individual
causal effects for all the different
runners in the sample
and these relate to the average
treatment effect which is the average of
all of those individual level causal
effects
and this visual is really helping to
cement my understanding of that
so then i
proceed
to learn more about the average
treatment effect i get to see different
kinds of visualizations of what that
data might look like and then i'm
tested on my knowledge
which hopefully should help to ensure
that i remember it in the future
that's pretty cool i will go back and
learn more about that later but now i've
learned enough that i can make an
initial choice
and i've also learned that i may need to
revisit this later
depending on what i see in my data but
for now this this should do
i'm going to let the program know some
features of my study so that it can help
me interpret the results down the line
and i know that i don't have a
randomized experiment so i'm going to
choose observational here i don't have
survey weights or nested data
so i'll save my design and move on
now i have stata data
but turns out that is not a problem even
though this is an r based
program we know our is good at uploading
all kinds of different kinds of data
that holds true here too
and it's already classified a bunch of
my variables as either covariates or
treatment it correctly classified this i
just need to pull out the outcome from
the set of variables and move it over
here
post treatment variables is a concept
that's new to me but this hover over
really helps me understand enough
to know that i've classified things
correctly
okay now i'm moving on to a screen that
lets me i guess modify some features
of the data so for instance if i want to
rename
my variables i got to say there's
nothing more annoying than inheriting a
data set where you didn't name the
variables
and they don't really make sense to you
so it's really lovely to be able to
quickly rename things
so that they
resonate with what you understand about
the variable
i don't have any missing data in this
particular data set but it's nice to
know that if i did in the future
that would be reflected here
so i'm going to save and move on and i'm
immediately
bump to a screen where i get to explore
my data more visually
which is lovely because sometimes i'm
too lazy to do this myself and i do it
after the fact and it's good practice to
be exploring my data before i move on to
an analysis
this shows a scatter plot of
child birth weight versus their age 3
test scores
and if i throw in a linear regression
line i can see a positive trend there
but what's really interesting to me
is the difference between the treated
observations which have been color-coded
as yellow
and the control which have been
color-coded as purple because what i'm
seeing here is that most of my treated
observations are down here
in this lower end of the spectrum and i
guess that's not surprising
because
as i'm as i'm remembering right now this
program was only offered to children who
were low birth weight
so i had forgotten that feature of the
data set and
that's going to become really important
to my analyses so i'm glad this plot
helped to remind me of that it's also
nice to know that i could look at any
particular data point i want just by
highlighting it and then the information
will pop up down here
okay but i want to explore this overlap
issue more so i'm just going to jump to
that
section and i'm going to ask to see
an overlap plot based on birth weight
and there it is
so this is confirming what i was
what i thought i saw before and what i
recall from how the program was
implemented
all the kids in the treatment group this
is their distribution of birth weights
these are all on the low end of the
spectrum in fact there's a cutoff at
2500 whereas this is a more you know
typical range of birth weights for
children
uh which
spans the gamut and
what i am taking away from this is i
probably don't want to be making any
kind of causal inference about the
children in this part of the birth
weight distribution because there's no
one who looks like them who got treated
so there's no counter factual for them
in my data
so that says i really want to be
focusing on the effect of the treatment
on the treated which is what i learned
from that initial learning module
great so i'm going to change that here
i'm going to say no to this
i'm not going to look at subgroup
analysis i'm not going to pre-specify
but it's good to know that i could if i
needed to do that up front
and then i'm just going to fit my model
now i know that
some of these fancy algorithms take a
while to run so oh well that wasn't too
bad
that's good to know i'm going to switch
this to histogram so what's going to
happen here is i'm presented with a
posterior distribution of the treatment
effect
i can throw in visualizations for the
mean
median
for confidence intervals
that's really helpful
and then
i also get a numeric display here of
confidence intervals etc
another nice feature is it's
interpreting
the output for me in terms of a sentence
that i could throw in a report or
journal article that uses appropriate
causal language
but equally important if i'm in a
position where i don't feel comfortable
making a causal statement i don't
think i
um that the causal assumptions have been
satisfied i don't have enough
confounders to condition on etc
then i can
use this non-causal interpretation which
will still
steer clear of some of the pitfalls of
interpretations that
often fall somewhere in between so
that's great i can also download this
plot as i can download any of the plots
terrific if i want to
see results by subgroups
i could
look at something like oh what's the
difference between the treatment effect
for kids whose moms were married when
they're born versus others
that's not really interesting from a
policy point of view i was just kind of
interested
individually since i'm a single mom but
anyway i will
move on and come back maybe for that
kind of exploration later but for now i
really need to get this report out
but that brings me to another issue
which is that i really need to
have code that i can share with
colleagues i'm going to want to go back
to this analysis later
some of my co-workers may need to
reproduce what i'm doing
if i publish a journal article i may
need to share code
but luckily if i go to this tab i see
that there's a log of what i did and in
fact i can download a complete script of
everything i've done which makes what
i've done fully reproducible
that is a huge relief
okay
so it seems like i have all the things i
needed
i learned something about causal
inference i got the results that i
needed to get
i got some different options about how
to present the results
i can download any of the plots i made
as well as the code i used
that really helped me out this afternoon
and took what could have been a many
hour or many day job and helped me
accomplish it in just a few minutes
so i'm pretty excited about this new
software and i hope you will be too
okay
so i swear i'm almost done okay
so what's next
we still need to build out our
analytical and educational components
and for that we need you
so please try out the software if it's
at all interesting to you here's the
link
give us feedback in the top right corner
there's a place where you can click to
give us feedback
uh spread the word through whatever
mechanism is your favorite mechanism
particularly if you're happy with it
and join the cause
so please contact us if you
are a shiny programmer and want to be
involved or you love causal inference
you like building educational things
we'd love to hear from you thank you so
much
thank you very much